professor on if you were to advise an
actor who is slated to play a police
officer that will be entering a fresh
crime scene what are some essentials
that actor should know some details that
really people only in law enforcement or
forensics would know about well the
first thing that the first rule of a
first responder which is what we call
the first officer on duty is
preservation of life they have to go in
and make sure if there's any bodies are
they alive and if they are the crime
scene be damned you have to preserve
their you do what you can to preserve
the life get the EMTs and get the
paramedics stuff like that unfortunately
it comes sometimes comes at the at the
the detriment of the crime scene of the
prayer of the preservation of the crime
scene that said once you've secured that
once you've once you've taken care of
that then you can preserve the crime
scene and by that I mean put up a
perimeter set up the yellow tape make
sure nobody comes in and out make sure
the press stays way way far away you
don't you don't want to allow people in
that don't belong there and one of the
rules that we have is kind of like Boy
Scouts pack it in pack it out you walk
in and you walk try is the best you can
to walk at backwards the same way you
came in people don't understand that and
don't get that because walking backwards
in front of a camera is not a good thing
but that's what we actually do with with
the first responder the second thing I
have to say is study your role intently
Ian McKellen who I met when I was just a
kid had told me that read your material
in depth before you start to anything so
I'd asked him about a Shakespearean play
and he says I never read the play I just
do the scene but you need to read
everything you're you're young so to the
neophyte or the or the the young officer
in training i would say read books read
websites you don't have time to read
books read journal articles read
websites look look things up expose
yourself if there's going to be dead
bodies expose yourself to pictures of
dead
there's plenty of websites out there
that have things like that that's
basically what i would say in terms of
an emotional response would most
officers just keep their composure in
terms of like what if they see something
involving children or just something
that's very disturbing would most
officers probably just they'd still have
to remain non emotional yes okay yes you
have to keep your emotions in check
would be a good way to a good way to say
it you have to maintain integrity of the
scene and yourself at all times media
has ways of finding out what's going on
at a crime scene they have microphones i
can pick things up at three miles you
know whatever they have their ways of
finding that I incident that happened
years ago where people were eating
doughnuts and laughing the command post
and they were setting things up and
trying to get it going and the media
picked up on it and they that department
got lambasted if that's not something
that's appropriate you have to stay with
dignity and respect one thing I always
teach my students is when referring to a
person that has passed away they are
decedent's they're not corpses they are
not dead guys they're not bodies if they
are decedent's that is the best way to
pay respect
yeah and is there a gender specific
terminology or no it's always decedent
and if it's we don't know who the person
is is it a Jane Doe or that's Jane Doe
John Doe is very very prevalent so Jane
Doe one Jane Doe to Jane Doe three
sometimes coroner's offices will label
them Jane Doe and the date things like
that so yes they're still we would still
call gender gender nonspecific and call
them two seasons but yes we would call
them officially in a report until
they've been identified of course then
you would label them by their by their
name and generally you would say you
know mr. Roberts or whatever for you
don't leak names out into the press
usually until something's been really
adjudicated which means it's gone
through all the way through court and
through trial sometimes you don't
release information like that you you
preserve the integrity of the decedent
in terms of approaching the decedent
let's suppose the officer realizes okay
we have someone that has passed away how
are they approaching the body they have
gloves on yes a hazmat would be involved
you have to be very very careful when
approaching a decedent because you don't
know if they have AIDS or if they have
other communicable diseases STDs things
like that so wearing gloves wearing
proper hazmat materials they have
disposable materials from footies to
head to the head to the the head of
everything in between and they're like
five dollars it's it's no big deal
they're disposable it is better to be
protected because you never in this day
and age you never know with hepatitis C
and other communicable diseases like
that that our highly contagious are
highly easily spread you have to protect
yourself so then let's suppose they were
protected to had gloves maybe some
footies or whatever how would they touch
the the decedent let's suppose they
wanted to move him or maybe they
wouldn't move them what would happen
would that only be the EMTs or the
coroner's office that would move this
seemed very good question the coroner's
office actually there's a corner /a Me's
office which is medical examiner the
coroner is the sometimes as many times
the sheriff corner the Orange County
Coroner is the is the Orange County
Sheriff NL in south of Los Angeles but
the medical examiner is the squad that
takes care of examining the body and
they will be the ones that come in and
move it and I don't say it move them and
take care of the examination and you are
not allowed you are allowed to protect
and preserve but you're not allowed to
remove or move you can pass them down
and look for a wallet for identification
stuff like that be very very careful
they may have a needle in their pocket
and even if you're wearing gloves no
shame doesn't matter needles are sharper
than any glove you're wearing unless
you're wearing you know industrial
strength but the emmy is the one that
they will yell at you if if you've
touched the body moved it because and as
I teach in my courses you can see if a
body has been moved or has been moved
and it's very important I mean a five
minute of rolling it over could change
that if it could be the difference
between knowing that it was laying down
or not now not knowing if it was laying
down or on its side or whatnot and that
can completely can change the outcome of
the investigation so when this officer
is going to this crime scene where are
they checking for the pulse to see if
they have a decedent
to see if it is a crime scene yea though
well that's two things the best thing is
the the wrist of course or the carotid
artery which I free which side that's on
I don't do that part and then as to if
is a crime scene or not always just I
don't say pretend always assume that
it's a crime scene until proven
otherwise that is the best formula for
invest for an investigation you can
always also another thing with the
perimeter that I talked about with the
yellow tape and all that you can always
push it out further because you can
always pull back when you need to so you
may start off with having a perimeter
that's five blocks wide because you
don't know where the the killer may
still be in the neighborhood assuming
there's a killer of course but as you
find out no it's just located at the
howse then you can pull things in or a
lot of times we're under a time
constraint if you're on a freeway say a
freeway shooting happened you close down
the freeway people are going to get
ticked off you don't want it closed any
longer than you have to you have to get
in get it done right and get out you
have one chance that's one of the most
important rules of any scientific
investigation is you have one chance to
preserve it to document it to collect it
and particularly when it comes to like a
freeway you cannot go back to the next
day your prior crime scene has been
compromised at that point same thing
with a house not too bad you can lock
down you can say nobody can get in here
you know it's preserved in lighting
terms it's a hot set um things like that
is you can you can you can leave it as
it is
you